hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot more fun and less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is how to work with these scores
and standard normal distributions so if
you have a population you're studying
some aspect of that population what
you'll find is that you know your data
is distributed in this normal
distribution okay sometimes referred to
as a bell curve because of the shape and
you can see right down the middle here
this is a x-bar that's the mean 50% of
the data is going to be above the mean
or the average and 50% is going to be
below but if you look at the standard
deviations okay of your data set you
know if you go one standard deviation to
the right of the mean above the mean
okay greater than the mean you can see
that will encompass 34% of the data or
if you go one per standard deviation
below the mean that's 34% of the data or
if you're one person standard deviation
either side of the mean that's
encompassing 68% of the data but
sometimes it doesn't always work out
where you were dealing with the exact
multiples of standard deviations like
one standard deviation two standard
deviations and so that's where the
z-scores come in so here's our formula
for calculating the z-score KZ equals
your data point minus the mean divided
by the standard deviation so what this
does for us is that it's calculating how
many standard deviations positive
meaning above the mean or negative
meaning below the mean that your data
point is and their standard normal
distribution tables in your textbook or
online and you can find out exactly what
percentage you know you're dealing with
okay whether it's you know above the
mean below the mean now the way a lot of
these tables work okay most of them work
is that when you find out let's say your
z-score is like one point let's just say
let's say it's 2.5 standard deviations
above the mean let's say it's right
there what the table will do is will
give you the percentage that are at that
value or below so it's always going to
give you this area of this
it's to the left of that z-score or that
number of standard deviations so if you
wanted to calculate the amount above
since this area underneath this curve is
1 or you could think of it as a hundred
percent you would have to actually do 1
minus this area to get this little area
above that to the right okay so that's
something to be aware of so again X is
our data point x-bar is the mean and
then Sigma is our standard deviation so
let's look at an example to see how we
work with this so say that the average
height of a student in your school is 65
inches okay with the standard deviation
of three inches find the probability
that if you pick somebody at random that
their height is less than or equal to 60
inches okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and use our
z-score formula we have Z equals okay 60
which is our data point minus the mean
which is 65 that's the average height of
a student divided by 3 which is our
standard deviation so if we calculate
that out we get let's see negative 5/3
okay which is approximately let's see
negative one point seven if we round to
the tenth okay so what you can do is you
can take a look at a standard normal
distribution table and if I go to
negative one point seven okay I can see
that it's point zero four four six okay
so this is point zero four four six so
what that means is if we go over here to
negative one point seven right there
okay the area to the left of that line
okay this part of the curve that area is
going to be about four point five
percent okay so point zero four four six
if you convert that to a percentage
that's about four point five percent so
the probability would be or the chance
would be four and a half percent that
somebody would be lower than that height
or shorter than that height okay let's
go to the next one say that the
probability that you pick somebody at
random that they're greater or taller
than seventy inches so same formula Z
equals 70 - 65 the mean divided by the
standard deviation here we're getting a
proc
ly+ 1.7 okay so if we go over here to
1.7 that's gonna be right about here
okay and we're trying to find the
probability that somebody is tall or
greater so meaning to the right okay now
if we go to our standard normal
distribution table or chart you can see
here that it's going to be about point
nine five five four okay so point nine
five five four
but that's giving you the area to the
left
okay below we want the area that's above
to the right so what we have to do is we
have to do one minus point nine five
five four and we get approximately point
zero four four six okay which is again
about four point five percent chance
that somebody's going to be taller okay
than 70 inches okay so they're with me
so far
okay last example so you want to find
the probability that you're in between
sixty inches and seventy inches tall
okay so what you would do is you would
calculate the two z-scores like we did
here but you're trying to find you know
let's draw this curve again you're
trying to find the probably that you're
in between here and here okay so this is
represents 1.7 standard deviations above
the mean
okay the mean is right down the middle
and negative 1.7 standard deviations
below the mean okay and we're trying to
find the area here in between those well
the way that the charts work is that
it's giving you the area below so when
we do positive 1.7 it's giving us this
area 0.95 five four okay which we got
from the last problem what we have to do
is we have to subtract off this area
here to give us the leftover so we're
going to take the point nine five five
four minus this area here which we got
was point zero four four six and that's
going to be this leftover area here
which I did that calculation for us here
and that comes out to 0.9 one zero eight
point nine one zero eight so that means
it's about a ninety-one percent chance
that somebody's going to be you know
greater than sixty inches but less than
70 inches so I hope this video helps you
understand how to work with z-scores and
standard normal distributions if you're
enjoying these videos and you're
learning something please subscribe to
the channel check out some of my past
videos and I've got more videos coming
like this for you so I look forward to
seeing you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon